okay okay just hear me out what if we
shot it into the sun Foster asked
excitedly you are aware just how far
away the sun actually is right his
fellow researcher Rhys replied sawing
with exhaustion at their lengthy
conversation they had been discussing
this for so long that the food on both
their trays had gone unappetizingly cold
obviously but okay
okay we'd be sending it into a
perpetually burning nuclear furnace
there is no way it would be able to
survive researcher Foster rebutted
standing by his latest hair brain Theory
we'd send it up into a rocket fully
automated so no Personnel have to put
themselves In Harm's Way and sacrifice
their lives then boom it flies into the
sun problem solved so it never occurred
to you that 682 might figure out a way
to escape on the 150 million kilometer
Journey Rhys poked at his mashed
potatoes with a fork out of boredom
you're forgetting how intelligent the
thing is it might be an omnicidal
killing machine but it's as smart as
either of us well one of us to say the
least sitting opposite each other in the
mess hall researcher Foster and
researcher Reese kept up their bickering
debating on what would be the best way
to neutralize
scp-682 the infamous hard to destroy
reptile it was a discussion nearly every
member of foundation Personnel had been
a part of at least once how could they
kill this unkillable Beast what other
anomalies were they yet to try and use
against it even after countless tests
most leading to numerous containment
breaches and significant loss of life
the foundation seemed to be no closer to
putting a definitive end to scp-682 but
while Reese and Foster debated more and
more outlandish possibilities someone
was sitting nearby listening in on every
word at a table all by himself in the
mess hall a man in typical Foundation
security officer Garb was quietly
squalling everything the pair of
researchers were saying on a notepad the
photo identification and name tag he
wore on his uniform identified him as
one Elias Anderson a long-serving member
of the SCP Foundation with an extensive
service record logged in their personal
database of course that name and the
whole identity were just a cover the
real officer Elias Anderson was dead his
body being kept on Ice hidden in a
morgue within a secure black site it
hadn't taken long for the man now
wearing Anderson's uniform and using his
name to update the officer's photo photo
with one of his own face in the
foundation's database keeping his
subterfuge so far undetected Gathering
up his notepad casually hiding it under
his tray as he stood up and walking
towards the mess hall exit the unknown
infiltrator made his way to the nearest
elevator riding it up to the highest
level making sure any other passengers
had gotten out on other floors the
security officer flipped the emergency
stop switch he reached into his pocket
retrieving a jury-rigged handheld
communication device and began sending a
message on a secure Channel agent
parados checking in he wrote the SCP
Foundation is still bickering amongst
themselves about the best way to
eliminate the target
scp-682 remains contained but alive
advise best course of action the cursor
on screen blinked for a few seconds
awaiting a response excellent work agent
the reply from GOC command finally
arrived lines of text scrolling rapidly
across the screen as long as this
anomaly is allowed to live it poses an
ever-present life to all threat on Earth
what is assessment of the foundation's
approach to termination parados thought
to himself for a moment before sending
back they're overthinking it affirmative
the Coalition wrote have the o5 council
still deny termination of scp-682 via
nuclear weapons the undercover agent
quickly responded confirming that this
was indeed still the case there was
another pause almost like the whole GOC
was thinking carefully about what to do
next Global occult Coalition Executives
have conferred and private to authorize
a hammer down operation to eliminate the
anomaly known as
scp-682 came the follow-up from command
an F-22 Raptor fixed with a 60 Megaton
payload will be launched at 0600 Bound
for the following coordinates a map
reference quickly followed the longitude
and latitude of a large empty area of
the Pacific Ocean agent parados your new
objective is to lure the creature into
the open by any means necessary GOC out
slipping the communicator back into his
pocket paratos unclicked the elevator
stop switch and pressed one of the
numbered floor buttons he already knew
which one would take him back down to
682's containment cell and what to do
when he got there the commotion was
unlike anything parados had ever seen
before alarms were blaring so loud that
the sound was ringing in his ears most
of the research staff were fleeing for
their lives while heavily armed mobile
task force operatives in tactical gear
were moving in formation to support the
security Personnel some had abandoned
their posts out of sheer Terror
desperately looking for anywhere they
could hide in order to stay alive under
the ear splitting whale of alerts was a
cacophony of chaos a mix of hailing
gunfire from the mtf's weapons the
crumble of walls is the facility around
them was being torn apart and the
angered vicious Roars of the rampaging
reptile all hands were on Deck the
foundation while always on high alert
had been caught completely unprepared
for a Containment Breach
scp-682 was making short work of any
living Personnel in its path carving
them up with its claws or devouring them
while they were still alive leaving a
trail of blood and destruction in its
wake any survivors on site were quickly
instructed to retreat into the command
center and parados casually slid in
alongside a gaggle of panicked
researchers he recognized one of them
from the mess hall researcher Foster
wide-eyed and disassociating in shock
the blood of his colleague Rhee is still
wet on his face and lab coat the outer
doors of the command center were locked
down while all efforts inside were put
towards coordinating the recontainment
effort tracking the escaped anomaly's
movements via a live satellite feed
agent Prados had to think and act fast
the hard to destroy reptile was already
making its way towards water where GOC
fighter jets would enrage it in order to
make the anomaly follow them to the
Target area but if the foundation had a
chance to recapture scp-682 his entire
Mission would be declared a failure
checking that nobody was watching parado
snuck over to a computer terminal
looking underneath he located the panel
and unscrewed it as quickly and
inconspicuously as he could reaching for
his Communicator he put the device into
one of the ports underneath the terminal
and it instantly went to work installing
proprietary software that would block
any outbound Foundation communication
hey Foster standard spotting parado
sabotaging the terminal hey hey what is
he doing within moments the researcher
had gained the attention of the
surviving security Personnel who rushed
over and tackled The Saboteur the
officers restrained paratos when
grabbing each of his arms as they held
him in place but it was too late
communication suddenly went offline
cutting the command center off from the
rest of the foundation who are you one
of the security guards yelled over and
over again punching the infiltrator in
the gut each time who do you work for
fighting through the pain parados had
kept his jaw clenched so tightly that he
could feel his teeth grinding together
like they were about to crack we still
have access to all saved internal data
one of the foundation technicians a man
named Baxter chimed in after examining
the computer terminal according to the
security footage he's the one who sprung
682. do we still have no comms Foster
has timidly still trying to wipe Reese's
blood off of his coat negative the
technician answered whatever this device
is it's deactivated every way we have to
transmit we can still receive though his
voice trailed off reducing to match the
low silence that was now filling the
command center everyone in the room
including the restrained agent parados
had gradually turned to face the massive
screens displaying the satellite footage
of scp-682 it was small but visible
thanks to how zoomed in the orbital lens
was the hard to destroy reptile had
reached the water and was making its way
across the ocean at the same time the
bird's eye feed of the Pacific showed
something else a tiny winged object
barreling through the air at almost
supersonic speeds that's a fighter jet
one of the security guards declared
breaking the tent silence probably a
raptor by the looks of it it was in fact
a fighter jet speeding towards scp-682
the creature seemed unaware of the
aircraft it was merely traveling in the
opposite direction but the pair were on
a direct course with each other bound to
meet at any moment now something ejected
from the F-22 that exact moment it
passed over the hard to destroy reptile
followed almost instantly by a bright
flash of light a huge explosion engulfed
the area of the ocean where the creature
had been a ball of radioactive fire in
the middle of the water the foundation
Personnel in the command center watched
in horror at the nuclear detonation
holding their breath dreading what they
would see when the mushroom cloud
dissipated he's with the Coalition the
nearest security guard realized
referring to piranhas it was well known
amongst the staff that the SCP
Foundation maintained a somewhat fragile
alliance with the global occult
Coalition while they had historically
worked together when their goals aligned
the GOC were more intent on destroying
anomaly's wholesale wiping them from
existence in order to protect the United
Nations and peoples of the world the
foundation on the other hand although
never afraid to get their hands dirty
but more of an emphasis on containment
and study of anomalies rather than
outright extermination what the hell
have you done you maniac yelled one of
the doctors trapped in the command
center a monstrosity needed to be
eliminated Prados argued back while you
were wasting your time keeping it
submerged in acid ready for it to break
out again and start slaughtering people
we acted and look for yourselves it
worked you should be thanking the GOC in
me because it turns out 682 wasn't
Invincible after all no it isn't Foster
spoke up Rhys and I were talking about
it earlier he said 682's greatest
strength isn't being invulnerable it's
being adaptable it can change itself
mutate in response to damage or in order
to survive a hostile environment and you
just you haven't killed it you've
allowed it to adapt to a nuclear weapon
on the screens something bursts from
underneath the water the overhead view
from the satellite feed filled the
display an image of a dark Rocky surface
who zoomed in on the feed pull it back
Baxter announced trying to hide what
they were all afraid of now that the
footage wasn't zoomed in at all it was
just looking at something much bigger
now as the camera zoomed out increasing
its field of view would look like a dark
surface on screen now looked to be a
huge mass of scales the satellite feed
pulled further back revealing the full
extent of what was now standing in the
Pacific Ocean it was
scp-682 not only still alive but much
much bigger than before the creature had
adapted to the intense heat of the
nuclear payload that had been dropped on
it soaking up the bomb's radiation and
using it as a way to increase its body
mass several million times over
um it looks like we have um Baxter said
dumbfounded eyes widen in horror uh
Kaiju on our hands burratos stared up at
the screen looking at the Monstrous
reptile now so much bigger than before
even from the satellite's current
overhead angle
scp-682 looked like it could now Tower
over most buildings say for maybe
occasionally tall skyscrapers what's
more the creature was now thrashing and
roaring in the ocean entering an enraged
State now infinitely more devastating
thanks to its Newfound size and it was
all paratus's fault hey Foster yelled at
the restrained GOC operative we need to
get the word out and the rest of the
facility is still on lockdown whatever
you did to disabled Communications
reverse it what good would that do
Prados asked in a blind panic look at
the size of that Abomination now it'll
wipe us all out oh god what have I done
the agent was shocked into Silence by a
sudden slap the timid researcher Foster
had struck him sharply across the face
cry about it later this is on you but do
you want to be part of the solution or
keep being part of the problem Foster
yelled gripping paratos by the caller I
I can't reverse it it replied I blocked
all outbound Foundation Transmissions my
com device is the only thing that wasn't
affected good enough Foster said holding
a handout to Baxter who passed him the
confiscated GOC attack then you're going
to contact the Coalition for us what for
foundation has a joint project we've
been working on with them and hi Brazil
for just this sort of occasion the
researchers stated holding out the
device to agent parado says the security
finally released his arms if there was
ever a time we needed it it's now wait
you mean parados finally realized what
Foster meant you're talking about the
dragon slayer aren't you the next hour
flew by time seemed to be moving faster
as the newly mutated scp-682 swam
through the waters of the Pacific it was
traveling in the Northwest Direction the
collection of foundation Personnel still
locked in the command center having
projected that it was heading for the
nearest land mass which meant it would
reach Hawaii at any moment throughout
the entire time Foster paratos and
Baxter were sending urgent communiques
to the global occult Coalition trying to
get them to cooperate and engage in
contact with the wider SCP Foundation
beyond the facility they were currently
stuck in not one of them knew which was
harder trying to kill an unkillable
lizard that had absorbed a nuclear blast
or trying to force the GOC and
Foundation to work together without
arguing over whose fault this whole mess
was all the while the Towering monstrous
reptilian form of scp-682 was getting
closer and closer to its destination
drawing itself up to its full enlarged
height
scp-682 roared large enough to block out
sunlight and cast an ominous Shadow over
the Hawaiian coastline onlookers watched
in Terror as the hard to destroy reptile
Rose from the water bearing down on
their Shores with the intent to
slaughter every living thing on the
island then just as scp-682 neared the
landmass the creature paused it could
hear something getting closer getting
louder as it approached from behind no
above and with it came the sound of
someone reciting poetry before the
creature could turn to face its attacker
the piercing metal of the cold iron
sword plunged through its scaly back and
out through its front the hard to
destroy reptile roared at the Searing
pain of the Stab Wound whipping its tail
as it thrashed in its Fury something
heavy and metallic deflected the swipe
of the creature's tail it was a huge
robotic arm of a gigantic mechanized
Titan it was
scp-5514 the dragon slayer controlled by
its skilled Pilots with a swift fluid
motion s 5514 delivered a brutal
backhanded strike to the reptile snout
staggering the Beast while also
withdrawing its mighty cold iron sword
at the same time
scp-682 round in discontent even its
infamously adaptable healing abilities
were halted by a wound from the Dragon
slayer's Blade watched by the innocent
civilians on the island and the
foundation through their satellite above
the Kaiju killing Mech assumed a
battle-ready stands as the hard to
destroy reptile reeled back to Roar the
moment it opened its sharp toothed Jaws
a fiery Atomic blast came spewing forth
from scp-682 it had adapted not only to
withstand the nuclear weapon the GOC had
used on it but also developed the
ability to unleash a burst of
radioactive Fire Within the Dragon
Slayer the Pilot's brace for impact as
the blast struck the outer armor of the
mech thankfully through the conceptual
engineer used when building it
scp-5514 was welded to the Earth itself
as well as the very concept of
Humanity's resilience back gave it just
enough protection against the onslaught
of
scp-682's new found ability holding up
one arm to defend itself the dragon
slayer reached upwards for its rounded
recoiling plasma the disc it wore as a
hat with its free hand with a spin it
flung the Razor Edge weapon at scp-682
like a frisbee it collided with a hard
to destroy reptile still unleashing its
nuclear fire breath and staggered the
crocodilian creature for just a moment
causing its blast to stop
scp-5514's Pilots commanded the mech to
charge forward as the rounded recoiling
plasma disc spun back through the air
and returned to the dragon slayer's hand
thanks to its built-in electromagnets
within the robotic vehicle the Thousand
word arrows were still loudly reciting
their poetry the mech's strangest weapon
was a group of seven people who would
rhyme and chant about the death and
defeat of the large-scale monsters
scp-5514 was designed to fight their
voices were being blared out of the
Dragon Slayer are a loud enough volume
to enrage
scp-682 further it roared again and then
started rushing towards its adversarity
the pair of colossal combatants
seemingly charging into a head-on
collision as it placed one mechanical
foot before the other huge splashes
erupting as its feet impacted the
surface of the ocean the dragon slayer
opened fire the Beowulf cigarette
railgun mounted on its shoulder began
launching electromagnetic energy bolts
at scp-682 the weapon used anomalously
altered gravity to blast its targets
with each hit the energy projectiles
seared through the outer scales of the
hard to destroy reptile while making the
Towering creature dramatically heavier
each projectile impacted at
superterminal velocities making
scp-682's already in large body feel
heavier and slower with every hit each
step it took seemed to sink deeper under
the ocean waves lapping at the reptiles
damaged scales sea salt washing over its
gaping wounds by the time it was about
with a dragon slayer the hard to destroy
reptile felt such huge forces of
additional weight acting on it that its
whole body was being pushed further and
further below sea level feet sinking
heavily into the sea floor below still
standing upright
scp-5514 raised its cold iron sword and
brought it down in one Fell Swoop
cleaving the creature's head from its
shoulders before wasting no time slicing
up what was left of its nuclear and
large body before long an area of the
Pacific Ocean was red with
scp-682's blood Victorious for now the
dragon slayer began Gathering up the
remains of the hard to destroy reptile
before it had a chance to reform its
body from the command center the
foundation Personnel cheered and whooped
excitedly even agent parados found
himself overwhelmed with relief although
he'd been sent with the intention of
assisting them and killing the hard to
destroy reptile the mission that the GOC
had sent him on had only made the
creature more of a threat for now at
least it was defeated although parados
is sound celebration of the fact was cut
short when one of the foundation doctors
tapped him on the shoulder excuse me GOC
agent parados isn't it the man asked my
name's Dr bright and this here is my
associate Dr clef we'd like to have a
word with you about the uh incident you
just caused now go and check out scp-682
craziest mutations and adaptations and
scp-682 weighs the SCP Foundation try to
kill the hard to destroy reptile to see
some of the extreme lengths the
foundation has gone to in their attempts
to kill scp-682